[Musique]
après la disparition de leur leader en
septembre 1970
Nasser a été durant plus d'une décennie
le porte-parole de toutes les causes des
peuples arabes
[Musique]
du cœur à Beyrouth de Damas à Jérusalem
il se sent orphelin et pleure autant
Nasser que leur sort en cette période de
désarroi du monde arabe
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la nostalgie de cette période là
parce que on a vécu une période de
tellement belle d'espoir
excusez-moi le dieu du monde
c'était le vrai dirigeant le seul
dirigeant si vous voulez du monde arabe
[Applaudissements]
dans les rues du Caire plusieurs
millions d'Égyptiens enveloppent le
cercueil de leur héros
avec l'insert s'en vont la fierté et le
rêve
ne reste que des illusions et de cruelle
déception
nasser est pour les uns leader qui a
défié les puissances occidentales pour
les autres le héros d'un nationalisme
arabe longtemps rempart contre
l'islamisme c'est un héros c'est un
homme qui a un moment donné dans
l'histoire était un phare pour le monde
arabe vous ne pouvez pas trouver un
meilleur dirigeant que Nasser mais à
cause de son régime dictatorial il nous
a mené à des désastres
[Musique]
arrive au pouvoir en 1952 à la suite
d'un coup d'état
il est le leader d'un groupe d'officier
nationaliste qui renverse le roi Pharo
un monarque corrompu
héritier d'une dynastie protégée par
l'empire Ottoman puis par l'Empire
britannique
ce mouvement des officiels libres met
ainsi fin à plusieurs siècles de
domination étrangères et instaure une
république
ces militaires sont des inconnus pour
les Égyptiens
ils trouvent leur porte drapeau en la
personne du général Mohammed homme
populaire et respecté
il va y avoir une lutte pour le pouvoir
entre lui et Nasser entre lui et les
officiers libres en fait entre autres
pour savoir quel type de régime
politique on va construire et notamment
si on va construire un régime
multi-partie ou bien
un régime tel que Nasser le souhaite
c'est à dire un régime en partie unique
Nagui veut instaurer une démocratie
parlementaire mais Nacer
[Musique]
pour contrer les projets de son
concurrent Nasser CONSOLID son emprise
sur l'armée il encourage la création de
nouvelles organisations de jeunes ou de
femmes qui lui font les gens
la confrontation entre le général Nagui
devenu président de la République et le
colonel Nasser son fils président durera
jusqu'à l'automne 1954
le 19 octobre Nacer signe un accord avec
le gouvernement de Londres pour
l'évacuation des derniers soldats
britanniques du canal de Suez il
apparaît ainsi comme le gardien de la
souveraineté égyptienne
[Musique]
quelques jours après la signature de cet
accord Nasser choisi Alexandrie pour
prononcer un de ses discours fleuves
dont il a le secret
Nasser commence à évoquer la genèse de
son engagement pour la liberté et la
dignité du peuple égyptien lorsqu'un
homme surgit de la foule et tire sur lui
comme à l'abdel
nasseries aucune ne l'atteindra
[Musique]
de retour au Caire nasser est accueilli
comme un miraculé un protégé d'Allah
acquérir ne peut arriver
il devient le héros d'une Égypte à la
recherche d'un chef d'un rice
désormais Nasser ne prend plus de gants
avec ceux qui se mettent en travers de
son chemin
l'opposition des Frères musulmans est la
plus importante et la plus structurée
cette organisation politique ou
religieuse qui veut imposer un
gouvernement islamiste était un allié de
Nasser avant le coup d'État
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'auteur de la tentative d'assassinat
sur la personne de Nasser Mohamed
Abdellatif est un membre des Frères
musulmans
[Musique]
condamné à mort il est exécuté
l'absence d'enquête indépendante laisse
planer encore aujourd'hui des doutes sur
les circonstances de cette tentative
d'assassinat
d'un point de vue historique je n'ai pas
trouvé de preuves irréfutable de ce qui
s'est réellement passé
selon Nasser les Frères musulmans
croyaient que le putsch de 1952
aboutirait un état islamique conforme à
leur idéologie
trahis et ont décidé de le tuer
les Frères musulmans ont une autre
version
pour eux Nasser avait fommenté cette
tentatives d'assassinat pour les
discréditer
avant de les éliminer et les emprisonner
plus d'un millier de Frères musulmans y
compris leur chef le guide suprême 6
d'entre eux seront exécutés il procède à
une épuration de la classe politique
égyptienne il emprisonne et on voit dans
des camps de détention tous les
opposants les communistes et les
partisans du général Naguib
accusé d'avoir trempé dans la tentative
d'assassinat à Alexandrie Nagui est
chassé du pouvoir et assigna résidence
il agit en
dictateur absolu il va rayer gommer
toute forme d'opposition et il va créer
les premiers camps des camps n'oserait
pas dire de concentration appelons ça
des camps de prisonniers des problèmes
le problème lorsqu’un dirigeant croit
qu'il est le seul à savoir ce qui est le
mieux pour le pays et pense que tous les
opposants sont soit des traîtres soit
des ennemis de la nation
en place un état policier avec
d'importants services de renseignements
tous les opposants sont ainsi mis sous
surveillance dans les prisons ou dans
des camps de détention
n'être absolu de l'Égypte Nasser veut
instaurer la justice sociale dans son
pays son seul programme politique
affiché
d'origine modeste il connaît la pauvreté
criante des masses paysannes
majoritaires dans la population
il confisque des terres au grand
propriétaire pour les redistribuer au
petit félin les paysans du
Nils impose à son pays des réformes qui
ne sont pas toujours conformes à l'islam
comme le contrôle des naissances ou
l'interdiction de la polygamie
mais il ne veut surtout pas apparaître
comme un communiste un athé aux yeux
d'un peuple profondément croyant alors
il multiplie les postures religieuses
comme celle d'accomplir plusieurs
pèlerinages à la Mecque
la principale préoccupation de Nasser
est le développement de son pays jusqu'à
une attaque de son voisin Israël en
février 1955
à la suite d'une opération de feday in
Palestiniens depuis la bande de Gaza
alors sous contrôle de l'Egypte les
représailles de l'armée israélienne font
plusieurs dizaines de victimes
égyptiennes
la doctrine en vogue à l'époque Israël
c'est qu'on ne laisse rien sans réponse
parce que la dissuasion d'Israël est à
ce prix pourquoi parce que le pays est
tout petit parce qu'il est entre les
ennemis c'est pour ça que aux incursions
de fedaïne répondent aux actions
violentes facteur israélien mais
vraiment un n'était pas très important
dans la politique
intérieure en Egypte mais lorsque
l'Israélien ont attaqué Gaza qui était
sous le contrôle d'Egypte il a trouvé
que il serait très difficile pour un
régime militaire d'accepter une telle
défaite humiliante
Nasser ne souhaite pas de confrontation
avec Israël mais il doit se préparer à
l'éventualité d'une guerre et cherche à
mieux équiper son armée
[Musique]
lors de la conférence des pays non
alignés à Bandung en Indonésie il
demande conseil au Premier ministre
chinois
celui-ci lui recommande de s'adresser
aux Soviétiques en cette période de
guerre froide Nasser sait que le
Moyen-Orient est dans la zone
d'influence des États-Unis il s'adresse
donc dans un premier temps aux
Américains
ceci lui demande en échange de signer le
pacte de Bagdad créé par la
Grande-Bretagne regroupant dans un
accord de défense Lirac la Turquie
l'Iran et le Pakistan
[Musique]
Nasser refuse de signer ce pacte puisque
rappelons-le-saère est un fervent
défenseur du non alignement niest new
West et on veut lui imposer ce pacte il
ne veut pas le signer on veut lui
imposer ensuite de faire la paix Israël
il y avait une entente entre les
ambassadeurs britanniques et américains
pour que les États-Unis ne livrent pas
d'armes au Caire tant qu'il n'y aurait
pas un accord de paix en Israël et
l'Egypte
Nasser refuse tout accord de paix avec
Israël il n'a pas d'autre choix que de
s'adresser à l'Union soviétique celle-ci
accepte sans condition car c'est une
occasion pour elle de mettre un pied au
Moyen-Orient chasse gardée de l'Occident
pour ne pas provoquer la colère des
Américains officiellement l'Egypte
achète des armes à la Tchécoslovaquie
mais les vrais fournisseurs sont les
Soviétiques
Nasser peut enfin équiper son armée de
matériel moderne
une armée dont il confie le commandement
à son fidèle ami Abdelhakim amer qui
cumule les fonctions de chef
d'état-major et de ministre de la
Défense
le colonel Nasser souhaite donner à son
pouvoir des apparences civiles en 1956
il se fait élire Président de la
République avec près de 100% de voix
pour réguler les crues du Nil et
constitué un réservoir d'eau pour une
agriculture qui fait vivre l'immense
majorité des Égyptiens Nasser rêve d'un
grand barrage à assouin
le git a besoin d'eau le Nil ne suffit
plus
en tout cas pour irriguer il faut un
barrage
et c'est vital il y va de la survie de
ce pays il va donc encore une fois se
tourner vers les Américains il essayait
d'avoir l'aide des Américains plusieurs
pour parler en eu lieu pour qu'on puisse
parce qu'il savait qu'il avait besoin du
barrage d'assois il avait besoin de
d'argent pour l'économie et de lancer
l'économie égyptienne
les Américains l'ont du paix au début
ils lui ont fait croire que oui on va
vous aider l'Amérique a réfléchi elle ne
prêtera pas l'argent en Égypte
donc cette humiliation là il a très mal
vécu les gîtes est à l'agonie d'où va
venir l'argent
donc c'est là qu'il pense au canal de
Suez quand toutes les portes ont été
fermées
[Musique]
quand il fait son discours il raconte
exactement pourquoi il le nationalise et
comment on l'a humilié et comment il a
frappé à la porte de l'Amérique et
comment il a supplié l'Angleterre et
qu'on lui on l'a on l'a renvoyé comme
comme un gueux comme un comme un moins
que rien c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire du monde arabe ou un homme
politique
tape du pied et leur dit vous voulez pas
m'aider c'est pas grave je peux me
débrouiller
vous pouvez imaginer le reste du monde
arabe quand il entend ce genre de
discours on est fier vraiment on était
fier en se disant au moins quelqu'un qui
dit non maintenant ça suffit on prend
notre destin en main j'étais chez le
responsable de notre partie il avait un
radio je crois il était le seul dans le
quartier qui avait en radio et nous
étions chez lui et comme nous étions
contre nous avons
considérable américain
nous avons continué à l'insulter à lui
accuser d'être agent et tout ça puis
quand il a dit
décision du Président de la République
de nationaliser
le canal de Suez
moi j'étais émue
et les larmes sont vraiment
bonne vie de mes yeux et couvert la
radio de ma joie
en nationalisant le canal de Suez Nasser
passe du statut de raïs à chaque à celui
de Zayn un guide un leader emporté par
un tapis magique d'une immense
popularité dans tout le monde arabe
ce geste de défi à l'Occident est salué
par la plupart des pays du tiers-monde
en Grande-Bretagne et en France
propriétaire de la Compagnie du canal de
Suez les réactions à l'égard de Nasser
sont sans nuances aucune dictateur
égyptien remportait un succès à
l'occasion du canal de Suez ce serait
une occasion pour un très grand nombre
de pays arabes de lui en boîte et pas de
le suivre nous avons raison de dire non
à Nasser et si nous avions dit non en
1936 Hitler nous n'aurions peut-être pas
eu la guerre de 1939-1945
la presse française et britannique en
boîte le pas aux dirigeants politiques
dans une hystérie digne de la propagande
de la presse égyptienne
[Musique]
ne vous y trompez pas ce n'est pas une
réincarnation ce n'est qu'une mauvaise
imitation
[Musique]
ils sont convaincus que que ce type
c'est un fou furieux écoutez il faut se
remettre dans l'esprit de cette époque
coloniale comment un esclave se révolte
contre son maître c'était ça le choc ce
qui avait fait Nacer n'avait rien de
particulièrement choquant il n'avait pas
fait un hold-up il avait nationalisé un
bien égyptien qui au demeurant serait
retombé dans l'escarcelle égyptienne
disant plus tard il y avait un bail de
100 ans donc en 68 le canal revenait à
l'Egypte de toute façon
deuxièmement de Gaulle avait bien
nationalisé les Charbonnages de France
en Angleterre avait nationalisé aussi
c'était ce n'était pas un acte absurde
dans la mesure où il
dédommager les actionnaires
semble belle pour les Britanniques et
les Français d'arrêter l'ascension d'un
ennemi qui gêne leurs intérêts dans le
monde arabe la Grande-Bretagne n'a pas
encore accepté son départ d'Egypte et
craint également l'extension de
l'influence de Nasser dans le golf arabe
où elle est encore présente
en cette année 1956 la France fait face
à des rebelles algériens soutenus par
les Égypte elle pense qu'en éliminant
Nasser elle pourra mettre un terme à
cette guerre de décolonisation
les Français et les Britanniques mettent
au point un scénario secret avec le
Premier ministre israélien David Ben
Gourion pour attaquer l'Égypte
égyptienne dans le Sinaï
c'est l'époque où nacelle vient de
signer mais non le contrat d'armement
avec avec la sauce Slovaquie avec une
soviétique et le bloc de l'Est
devienne une puissance militaire avec
laquelle c'est difficile de se mesurer
une fois que la digérer c'est géniaux
quantités
le 29 octobre 1956 les troupes du
général moucher Diane se lancent dans le
Sinaï en direction du canal de Suez
appuyé en secret par des avions français
les Israéliens trouvent peu de
résistance du côté de l'armée égyptienne
conformément au scénario élaboré avant
l'opération Londres et Paris envoie un
ultimatum à l'Égypte et à Israël pour
qu'il se retire du canal
la serre refuse
les britannique et les Français peuvent
alors s'engager dans le conflit
officiellement pour s'interposer entre
les Égyptiens et les Israël
le 5 novembre des parachutistes français
venus d'Algérie sautent près du canal
puis ce sont les commandos des Royal
Marines sanglets qui investissent les
plages et se dirigent vers Port Saïd les
deux rives du canal sont occupées et les
trois armées alliées se trouvent à deux
heures du Caire
son armée défaite Nasser cherche à
organiser la résistance populaire il
s'adresse à son peuple dans l'enceinte
de la célèbre institution religieuse et
Lazare pour le mobiliser
j'ai commencé à me rendre compte que mon
père était président
au moment de la guerre de 1956
car le début de la guerre nous a tous
surpris
mon père a demandé à sa famille de ne
pas quitter le Caire
durant l'offensive beaucoup de personnes
ont quitté la capitale pour la province
fuyant les bombardements
[Musique]
en cette période de crise nationale
Nacer adopte une attitude traditionnelle
pour mobiliser les foules
des monarques par le passé
une attitude qui consiste à user d'un
discours religieux
l'appel de Nasser au sentiment religieux
ne suffit pas à éviter une des routes
allégée la résistance populaire est
insuffisante et l'armée commandée par
Abdelhakim amer est anéanti le pouvoir
de Nasser est menacé
un ultimatum de l'Union soviétique et
des États-Unis sauvent l'Egypte les deux
grandes puissances obligent les trois
armées alliées à se retirer
les Américains veulent montrer que leur
pays émet du jeu au Moyen-Orient à un
moment où les Soviétiques menacent d'une
intervention pour venir en aide à son
seul protégé dans la région l'Egypte
la menace soviétique de lancer des
missiles sur Londres et Paris n'était
pas
prise au sérieux mais ce qui a été pris
au sérieux c'est la possibilité
de la présence des troupes soviétiques
dans le Moyen-Orient et je pense les
États-Unis
ne voulaient pas cette perspective la
seule fin d'intérêt claire et le seul
d'ailleurs qui vont gagner quelque chose
c'est Israël les autres vont devenir va
contre les gens après avoir renforcé la
scène
paradoxalement l'homme a été formidable
transformé des affaires militaires en
victoire politique
en contrepartie de son retrait du Sinaï
Israël obtient l'autorisation pour ses
bateaux d'emprunter le détroit de tyran
qui se trouve dans les eaux
territoriales égyptiennes sont seuls
accès vers la mer Rouge
les casques bleus de l'ONU garantiront
cette liberté de navigation ainsi que
les frontières internationales en
s'interposant entre l'armée israélienne
et l'armée égyptienne
[Musique]
le peuple égyptien n'est pas informé de
la concession faite à l'État hébreu le
retrait d'Israël de la France et de la
Grande-Bretagne est présenté aux
Égyptiens comme une victoire attribuée
au génie politique de Nasser
les Français et les Britanniques qui
vivent pour certains depuis plusieurs
décennies sont expulsés d'Egypte
la communauté juive présente dans le
pays depuis plusieurs siècles est accusé
d'être la cinquième colonne d'Israël
des milliers de Juifs quittent leur pays
pour la France les États-Unis et pour
Israël qui en accueillent près de la
moitié
[Musique]
vont être expulsés tous ceux qui ont des
passent pas français et britanniques qui
va avoir rupture des relations
diplomatiques évidemment
et aussi toute une série de gens qui
sont considérés comme des étrangers
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de passeport et
parmi eux il y a beaucoup de juifs mais
ce n'est pas l'expulsion de tous les
juifs mais ça va marquer le début d'une
d'une émigration juive qui va s'achever
en gros au début des années 60
la vérité est que l'Égypte a beaucoup
perdu sur le plan culturel et économique
avec le départ des étrangers
qui a été ébranlé
la tradition veut que toute personne qui
vit en Egypte soit traitée comme un
égyptien
qui depuis des siècles intègrent de
nombreuses diversités culturelles et
religieuses changent sous l'impulsion de
Nasser
l'identité arabe du pays et glorifié
Nacer se présente comme le leader du
panarabisme une idéologie qui prône
l'union de tous les Arabes
celui qui promet au peuple arabe la fin
des humiliations passées apparaît comme
l'héritier de Saladin le héros
arabo-musulman vainqueur des chrétiens
autant les croisades son discours parle
aux petits peuple les gens ont envie
d'entendre ça ils ont rêvé
d'entendre un homme qui leur dise la
nation arabe le monde arabe va lever la
tête nous allons devenir une puissance
fécrablement
le discours de Nasser fait de lui
inévitablement un mythe dans le monde
arabe
qu'il prenait l'unité arabe et le
nationalisme arabe
chaque citoyen des pays arabes pouvait
le considérer comme son propre dirigeant
être seulement un leader égyptien mais
un leader arabe
le mythe du panarabisme existait avant
Nasser en Syrie le principal promoteur
de cette idéologie est un chrétien
Michel à Flak qui appelle à l'union de
son pays avec l'Egypte
la dirigeants de Damas pensent que cette
union assurera une stabilité à leur
jeune nation pour les frontières ont été
tracés par les anciens colonisateurs
français et britannique pour eux le
panarabisme est un ciment entre les
différentes communautés religieuses et
culturelles qui vivent dans le pays
que la Syrie proche de l'Égypte
historiquement et culturellement et en
vérité le berceau du nationalisme arabe
en tant idéologie soit le premier état
dans cette union
arabe s'unissait il deviendrait une
puissance sur la scène internationale
entre l'Égypte et la Syrie est scellé au
Caire début 1958 entre gamma Abdel
Nasser et le président syrien pour
former une seule nation la République
arabe unie
l'événement suscite l'euphorie des
peuples arabes qui rêvent de rejoindre
cette union
[Applaudissements]
Adamas une marée humaine accueille
des Syriens viennent de toutes les
régions du pays pour aller à sa
rencontre
[Applaudissements]
les Arabes des pays limitrophes se
joignent aussi rien pour saluer le héros
de la grande nation arabe
[Applaudissements]
le plus bel accueil réservé à mon père
venait de Libanais qui avait traversé la
frontière pour se rendre à Damas
et avait attendu toute la nuit dans les
rues jusqu'au lendemain
plus de 300
libanais qui ont fait le voyage de
Beyrouth du Liban Adamas pour acclamer
cette union les musulmans du Liban ont
tout de suite voulu se jeter dans cette
union là et on estimé que le Liban
pouvait entrer aussi dans cette dans
cette communauté
cette agitation des musulmans libanais
fait peur aux chrétiens marronniers qui
rejettent tout rapprochement avec la
Nouvelle République arabe
déjà fragilisé par une crise
institutionnelle le Liban assiste à un
début de guerre civile
le président Camille Chamoun demande
l'intervention des États-Unis les
Marines américains débarquent à Beyrouth
et occupent le pays quelques mois le
temps d'éloigner toute velléité d'union
avec la République arabique
[Musique]
de son côté la Grande-Bretagne on voit
des parachutistes pour protéger le roi
ucène de Jordanie qui craint un coup
d'état d'inspiration la syrienne
il ne veut pas subir le même sort que
son cousin le roi d'Irak assassiné par
des officiers libres lors d'un coup
d'état
les appels de Nacer à une grande nation
arabe font peur à toutes les monarchies
de la région
l'Arabie Saoudite fidèle alliée des
États-Unis veut contrer l'influence
grandissante de Nasser
faire vérité une bataille historique
contre
l'arabisme
moderne et une idéologie
un gouvernement traditionnel
conservative
islamiste il y avait la guerre froide au
niveau mondial mais il y avait aussi la
petite guerre froide dans le monde arabe
entre le régime soi-disant promuciste et
le film soit disant réactionnel
[Applaudissements]
est célébré par les peuples les craints
par les dirigeants
dominateur il exerce un pouvoir sans
partage à la tête de la nouvelle
république arabes unis comme en Égypte
il interdit tous les partis politiques
en Syrie appelé désormais la province du
Nord
Nasser nomme son ministre de la Défense
Abdelhakim amer à la tête de cette
province qui vit désormais au rythme
imposé par le cœur
il a fait une très grande faute en Syrie
n'a pas compris que la série c'est une
société de la classe moyenne et c'est
une société ouverte c'est une cité
cultivée c'est une société c'est pas une
société pauvre
il a appliqué en Syrie les mêmes règles
de politique qu'ils avaient appliqué en
Égypte c'est pas une union ça va être de
facto une annexion par l'Egypte de la
Syrie avec une
importation en Syrie des méthodes
policières du régime nassérien
c'est-à-dire arrestation des opposants
tortues etc et une sorte de pillage du
pays qui va créer les conditions d'un
coup d'État en 1961 de séparation entre
le la Syrie et l'Égypte
l'expérience de la République Arabes
Unis prend fin en septembre 1961
les militaires syriens auteurs du coup
d'État remettent le pouvoir entre les
mains de la bourgeoisie écartées par
Nasser deux ans auparavant
la foule qui acclamait la serre en 1958
salue aujourd'hui l'arrivée des nouveaux
dirigeants les symboles de l'Ancienne
République Arabe Unis sont détruits
[Musique]
les Égyptiens installés dans le pays
sont indésirables pour nombre d'entre
eux c'est la fuite pour éviter les
représailles d'une population malmenée
il se dirige vers Beyrouth avant
d'embarquer pour l'Egypte en portant
avec le rêve panarade
[Musique]
le nationalisme n'est pas à mon avis un
projet politique
car on voit bien à travers l'histoire
que les projets construits sur une
identité un nationalisme sont
inéluctablement voués à l'échec face à
l'échec il va aller dans une on peut
dire une course en avant vers des
mesures plus radicales une deuxième
phase de la réforme agraire la
nationalisation du
de l'industrie de beaucoup de sociétés
étrangères ou égyptienne cette folie des
nationalisations à outrance où il a
donné aux gens 48 heures pour faire
leurs valises enfin ça a été une erreur
colossale et colossale il a décapité
entièrement en intelligence égyptienne
il a il a détruit un brassage culturel
qui était une source vide l'Egypte je
crois que cette folie est née parce
qu'il y a pas d'autres mots il folie
paranoïaque elle est née suite à la
rupture avec la Syrie il a eu peur que
les grandes familles égyptiennes ne
tentent la même chose en Égypte qu'en
Syrie
la bourgeoisie syrienne la chasse et de
Damas c'est la bourgeoisie
traditionnelle égyptienne qui ont paiera
le prix
à la tête des entreprises nationalisées
Nasser place des militaires qui
formeront bientôt une classe dominante
grâce aux revenus d'une corruption
généralisée
réforme agraire et nationalisation de
tous les secteurs le modèle économique
de l'Egypte ressemble à celui des pays
de l'Est
l'Union soviétique et son principal
allié et fournisseurs de machines et
équipements divers pour Nasser la
justice sociale passe par le socialisme
arabe un socialisme compatible avec
l'islam
pour ne pas non plus sombrer totalement
dans un état dans un esprit de
socialisme athée qui refusait il a parlé
de socialisme arabe nous pouvons avoir
nous-mêmes notre façon de voir les
choses notre façon de d'imposer
certaines conditions économiques et
culturelles
tout en gardant aussi notre culture
arabo-musulmane
le l'islam ne quitte pas l'esprit de nos
cerveau
Nasser c'est qu'une majorité de la
population égyptienne est attachée aux
valeurs traditionnelles de l'islam mais
la société est aussi soumise à d'autres
influences celle de la présence
soviétique au niveau économique et
culturel et celle de la modernité
occidentale qui séduit une partie de la
jeunesse urbaine
Nasser fait le grand écart entre toutes
ces influences il encourage la modernité
par conviction et fait des concessions à
l'islam traditionnel pas calcul
il finance l'expansion de l'importante
institution religieuse à Lazare en
contrepartie de sa soumission à son
pouvoir personnel
conséquence el hasard perd toute
crédibilité religieuse
les Égyptiens se tournent alors vers
l'islam rigoriste prenait par les Frères
musulmans qui répandent leurs idées dans
la clandestinité
Nasser cherche à contrer cette influence
croissante parfois on se moquant d'eux
dans ce discours
en 1965 il raconte une entrevue 12 ans
auparavant avec le guide des Frères
musulmans qui voulait imposer le voile à
toutes les femmes égyptiennes
[Applaudissements]
je suis entré à l'université en
1962-63 il n'y avait pas une seule fille
voilée à l'université même celle qui
venait de la campagne ne se couvraient
pas la tête
mais absolument pas le pays était
moderne nous l'étions tous qu'elle est
balade moderne
[Musique]
les images privées de Nasser ressemblent
à celle de nombreuses familles
occidentales sa femme et ses filles ne
se sont jamais voilées
outre le jeu d'échec qu'il pratique avec
son fils aîné ou des amis il affectionne
les films américains qu'ils regardent
dans sa salle de projection privée
Nasser n'a jamais caché son admiration
pour un certain mode de vie à
l'occidental
[Musique]
les jeunes Égyptiens qui obtiennent des
bonnes notes à leurs études
universitaires étaient envoyées pour
continuer leurs études supérieures aux
États-Unis
en Grande-Bretagne en France je pense
qu'il avait aucun problème avec la
culture
occidentale a été
rejeté vers le vers le bloc de l'Est et
lui qui détestait les communistes il
faut savoir que c'était un
anti-communiste notoire
et il est va se retrouver dans les bras
des communistes
[Musique]
le destin de Nasser est entre les mains
des Soviétiques qui avait stoppé
l'offensive tripartite de 1956 après la
nationalisation du canal de Suez l'Union
soviétique est devenue depuis une alliée
incontournable de l'Egypte
lorsque le dirigeant soviétique
accrochée
le reçoit à bras ouverts
durant les 15 jours de sa visite
l'accueil qui lui est réservé à
triomphale
[Applaudissements]
les Égyptiens lui sont redevables de
l'aide à la construction du barrage
d'Assouan inauguré en grande pompe
un barrage qui améliorera la vie de
millions de paysans de la vallée du Nil
[Musique]
coachev n'apprécie guère ne sert qui a
emprisonné des milliers de communistes
mais en cette période de guerre froide
l'Egypte est pour l'Union soviétique une
porte d'entrée au Moyen-Orient
les sentiments de Nasser pour kroutechev
ne sont pas meilleurs mais la
d'économique est militaire des
Soviétiques et vitales pour l'Egypte
surtout en cette période où le pays se
trouve enlisé dans une guerre au Yémen
une guerre civile dans laquelle sont
engagées les deux grands pays du
Proche-Orient arabe l’égypte et l'Arabie
Saoudite
[Musique]
est aux côtés d'officier républicains
qui ont renversé le roi du Yémen le
Calet soutenu par son voisin saoudien
Nasser qui cherche à s'imposer comme le
maître du monde arabe pense que c'est
l'occasion d'affaiblir l'Arabie Saoudite
qui lui dispute le leadership
[Musique]
était convaincu que les Forces
Républicaines gagneraient la guerre
il pensait aussi qu'il suffirait
d'envoyer quelques instructeurs une
petite aide militaire pour les mener
jusqu'à la victoire finale
avait considéré l'Arabie Saoudite comme
son contre Paul
et il a cru toujours aussi il va
dépasser cette obstacle saoudien le
monde arabe va complètement tomber dans
ses mains
plus fort qu'ils ne le pensaient
au Yémen qui est alors frontière comme
une menace avec laquelle il ne pouvait
pas vivre
considérables pour recruter des
mercenaires européens et d'autres pays
pour renforcer le camp monarchiste
le Vietnam égyptien
des milliers de mots de milliers de
gosses où on partir faire la guerre
là-bas et on peut vraiment comparer cela
à la guerre du Vietnam ça a été là le
début de la descente aux enfers
l'Egypte s'embourbe dans cette guerre
civile du Yémen qui se déroule à plus de
2000 km de chez elle l'armée égyptienne
engage des moyens importants et envoie
des soldats d'élite pour combattre aux
côtés des forces républicaines
dans ce moyen orient convoité par les
grandes puissances le Yémen est devenu
un théâtre de la guerre froide
les Soviétiques soutiennent l’égypte et
les républicains yéménite les forces
royalistes et l'Arabie Saoudite sont
elles aidées par les Américains et les
Britanniques
[Musique]
la présence militaire britannique encore
importante dans la région serait
directement menacée si une telle guerre
s'étendait à d'autres émirats du Golfe
[Musique]
cette guerre lointaine pèse lourd sur
l'économie égyptienne déjà fragile
quand je quitte l'Egypte en 65 l'Egypte
est à genoux il n'y a plus rien on
trouve plus rien dans le pays tous les
aliments de première nécessité sont
soumis à rationnement donc c'est un pays
ruiné l'Egypte des API ruinée en 65
malgré les difficultés économiques du
pays Nasser reste le leader du monde
arabe c'est vers lui que les peuples
arabes se tournent pour résoudre le
problème palestinien
l'organisation pour la libération de la
Palestine dirigée par Ahmed choukairi
s'établit au Caire ses meetings
enflammées nourrissent une surenchère
guerrière contre Israël
ton choukairi les Juifs qui sont venus
en bateau s'installer en Palestine
doivent repartir en bateau
les escarmouchent entre l'État hébreux
et ses voisins sont permanentes les
attaques de fedaïne Palestiniens sont
suivis de représailles aveugles
le détournement des eaux du Jourdain par
Israël crée de nouvelles tensions avec
les trois pays concernés le Liban la
Syrie et la Jordanie
[Musique]
c'est encore une fois vernacer que les
Arabes se tournent pour contrer Israël
pour le poussage la presse de plusieurs
pays arabes le traite de l'âge et
d'agents à la solde de l'Occident
la Jordanie la Syrie
ces pays-là et puis auquel se sont
joints d'autres voisins arabes ont dit à
Nasser mais enfin comment tu laisses
faire comment tu laisses bombarder
comment tu laisses tuer des Palestiniens
comment tu laisses tuer des Jordaniens
tu es le champion de la cause
palestinienne le champion du monde arabe
tu peux pas rester les bras croisés et
la pression était de plus en plus forte
se présentant comme leader du monde
arabe il doit offrir une solution à la
question palestidienne et pris par son
propre discours c'est vrai et par ces ça
rhétorique nationaliste arabe de défense
du monde arabe face à Israël face à
l'impérialisme ce qui fait la différence
entre un homme politique et un grand
homme c'est que le grand homme résiste à
la pression
il se laisse pas embarquer comme c'est
ici embarquer Nasser
Nasser consulte son ami et ministre de
la Défense le maréchal Abdallah Kim amer
celui-ci lui garantit la victoire en cas
d'affrontement armée avec Israël
[Musique]
Nasser demande alors à l'ONU de retirer
ses soldats qui s'interposent entre
l'armée israélienne et l'armée
égyptienne à la frontière entre les deux
pays
il décide également d'interdire l'accès
du détroit de tir à au bateau israélien
a du nom un signe concession faite à
l'État hébreu en 1956
Abdel Hakim amer qui a besoin de redorer
son blason après la cinglante défaite
militaires de la guerre de Suez déploie
ses troupes dans le Sinaï pour
impressionner l'ennemi
[Musique]
ne pensez pas que l'escalade mènerait
réellement à une guerre avec Israël
pour lui se démonstration de force avait
pour but d'intimider Israël afin
d'obtenir des concessions
même si les probable que la seule ne
voulait pas lui-même fait la guerre
il a poussé Israël dans un coin de la
seule la seule possibilité c'était de
faire la guerre il sera fini par
comprendre qu'il a pas le choix il doit
faire la guerre c'est que nous ne
savions pas c'est à quel point
l'armée égyptienne était mal préparée à
cette guerre
le 5 juin 1967 à l'aube Israël attaque
l'Égypte mais aussi la Syrie et la
Jordanie en quelques heures l'aviation
arabe est détruite au sol avant même de
décoller
sans couverture aérienne n'est trop
égyptiennes sont anéanties dans le
désert du Sinaï
en 6 jours les armées égyptiennes
syrienne et jordanienne sont vaincus
Israël conquiert l'ensemble des
territoires de la palestinie historique
y compris Jérusalem Est qui était sous
l'autorité jordanienne ainsi que le
plateau du colonne syrien et la
péninsule du snail égyptien
la défaite est totale et humiliante
des milliers de soldats égyptiens air
dans le désert du Sinaï abandonné par
leurs officiers
[Musique]
pendant ce temps la télévision et la
radio égyptienne diffusent des
communiqués de victoire
le radio soit annoncée que on avait
descendu 50 avions Israëliens que
l'armée celienne était en train de fuir
qu'on était à 200 mètres à 200 km de
Jérusalem que tout était réglé c'était
des débutants de victorieux à toutes les
heures c'était à l'époque un étudiant à
l'université et pendant la guerre j'ai
vu les troupes égyptiennes revenir du
front
j'ai demandé à mes amis mais qu'est-ce
qu'on voit devant nous
ils n'ont pas pu imaginer que c'est un
écrit des troupes égyptiens
[Musique]
ce n'est que le 9 juin que le peuple
égyptien est informé de la défaite lors
de l'allocution télévisée les Égyptiens
espèrent de leur guide retournement de
situation qui sauver le pays
après avoir dénoncé un complot
colonialiste et accusait les États-Unis
et la Grande-Bretagne est d'avoir aidé
Israël
Nasser reconnait sa responsabilité lui
annonce sa démission le Zaïm courage aux
yeux des Égyptiens termine son discours
en retenant ses larmes
mon père est rentré nous étions avec
quelques proches parents à la maison
puis nous avons commencé à entendre des
voix
beaucoup de gens
soudain les alentours de la maison ont
été envahis par une foule qui a commencé
à chanter des chants patriotiques
ces gens ont passé la nuit autour de la
maison jusqu'au petit matin
des centaines de milliers d'Égyptiens
viennent au cœur pour soutenir leur race
durant près de 48 heures ce sont les
mêmes scènes de colère et de douleurs
dans tout le pays les hommes et des
femmes de tous âges demandent un acer de
revenir sur sa démission
le peuple le plébiscite malgré le
désastre comme aucun dirigeant ne
l'avait jamais été avant lui
Nasser transforme un échec en triomphe
la reconnaissance par Nasser de sa
défaite dans une allocution très
émouvante à la télévision nationale fut
qu’il l’évolue ou pas un vrai coup de
génie
présente car l'image qu'il présentait
était celle d'une Égypte
optimiste puissante
complot international
global can Spirit
par les États-Unis et beaucoup d'autres
puissances mondiales qui ne voulaient
pas d'une Égypte de nouveaux fortes
se retrouvait avec une armée détruite
avec le sinaïque totalement
occupé avec le canal de Suez fermé il y
avait une vraie crise dont tout le monde
avait confiance et qu'il fallait d'une
manière ou d'une autre arriver à
résoudre et pour les Égyptiens ma sœur
apparaît comme celui qui va pouvoir
essayer de reconstruire ce qui a été
détruit des sondes ils ont pensé que
rester aux côtés de Nasser permettre à
Nasser de relever la tête était un acte
symbolique pour dire
nous n'avons pas perdu nous sommes
toujours debout ah oui il y a eu des
manifestations énormes dans Beyrouth en
disant non
on ne veut pas on refuse ta démission et
pourtant qu'est-ce que le Liban avec
l'Égypte son président
j'étais très très heureux quand il a dit
je vais rester pour quelques temps
jusqu'à
on va effacer les traces de l'agression
contre notre pays et le monde arabe
le retour de Nasser est annoncé par un
noir et s'adapte le président de
l'Assemblée du peuple
dès le lendemain Nasser Limoges
Abdelhakim
de la défaite
quelques semaines après le gouvernement
annoncera son suicide
pour se maintenir au pouvoir Nasser
procède à une vaste purge dans l'armée
et tout l'appareil d'État sous la
pression des autres pays arabes il
refuse tout accord de paix avec l'État
hébreu et se lance dans une guerre
d'usure
désormais l'objet de l'affrontement avec
Israël et la récupération de la
péninsule du Sinaï occupé et non plus la
cause palestinienne
la guerre de 1967 aggrave le sort des
Palestiniens qui vivent un nouvel exode
des dizaines de milliers d'entre eux
traversent le Jourdain pour aller
grossir les camps de réfugiés installés
en Jordanie
[Musique]
le sort des Palestiniens suscite un
sentiment d'humiliation dans tout le
monde arabe
une opportunité pour les islamistes qui
présentent la défaite des armées arabes
comme une punition divine ils accusent
les dirigeants arabes de cette éloignée
de l'islam seul source de puissance
la défaite de 1967 ne fut pas sans
conséquence elle fut un des facteurs du
développement de l'islamisme ajouter à
cela le fait que l'islamisme la essence
est un fascisme car il refuse toute
contradiction
c'est une idéologie qui se réfère à Dieu
dès lors si tu es contre elle si tu es
contre Dieu elle a donc le droit de
faire de toi ce que bon lui semble
les Frères musulmans le groupe le plus
important du camp islamiste
ont vu la défaite de 1967 comme une
revanche de leur idéologie une preuve de
l'échec du nationalisme arabe et du
pouvoir de Nasser pour eux c'est un
moment propice à leur retour
[Musique]
le régime d'assyrien a été considéré le
mouvement islamiste développé dans
l'ombre avant 1967 un vesti ouvertement
l'espace public
affaibli par ses échecs Nacer est
contraint à de nombreuses concessions à
l'islam au conservateur soutenus par
l'Arabie Saoudite
Nasser le leader du panarabisme moderne
baisse les armes face au chantre du
panislamisme traditionnel le roi Fayçal
les adversaires d'hier sont aujourd'hui
des alliés ils mettent fin à la guerre
du Yémen qui les opposait depuis 1962
c'est également ensemble qu'il
réconcilie au Caire le nouveau président
de l'Organisation de Libération de la
Palestine il a ses rares à le roi
Hussein de Jordanie suite à un
affrontement sanglant entre les
Palestiniens et les Jordaniens en
septembre 1970
le dernier acte politique de Nasser qui
fut combat une crise cardiaque le soir
même de cet accord de paix
[Musique]
lors de ces funérailles ça dépouille est
accompagnée dans les rues du Caire par
des millions d'Égyptiens qui chantent il
n'y a d'autres dieux qu'Allah et sont
bien aimé
[Musique]
il est inhumé dans une mosquée qui
portera son nom
merci à mort il n'y a plus de dirigeants
capables de s'adresser au monde arabe il
n'y a plus eu depuis une Acer un seul
dirigeant que le monde occidental aurait
pu écouter je pense que la sève est une
tragédie
arabe mais aussi australienne et son
échec qui lui a rejoint imputable sans
échec signifie l'échec du nationalisme
panorable laïque qui nous mène qui nous
mène là là où sont
le régime de Nacer avait été
démocratique s'il avait joué le jeu
démocratique Nasser aurait été plus
grand car il jouissait d'une réelle
popularité
le problème c'est que Nasser qui était
le plus loyal et le plus honnête des
dirigeants avait créé une machine
répressive
les dirigeants qui lui ont succédé ont
trouvé l'un un dispositif de répression
prêt à être utilisé
le régime dictatorial ne disparaît pas
pour autant
son ancien compagnon d'armes à noir
el-Sadate endos aisément la bille de
dictateur avec l'appui de l'État
policier mis en place par Nasser
sa date s'emplera à éliminer toute trace
d'une asserisme avec des alliés de
circonstance les islamistes qui
redeviennent la force politique
dominante
c'est la fin d'un vrai de modernité de
l'Égypte symbolisé un temps par la
fierté de cette paysanne qui d'une main
se dévoile et de l'autre s'appuie sur le
Sphinx de l'Égypte éternelle
[Musique]
le panarabisme de Nasser n'est déjà
qu'un loint un souvenir
dans tout le monde arabo-musulman
l'islamisme sous toutes ses formes ne
cessera détendre son influence
[Musique]
et les chauffe-eau
appeler ma chouette
[Musique]